I brought everything that I could find
in the supermarket that was making a
claim that it was good for me and I want
you to take a look at it that Tim
Spectre is definitely healthy or not
avoid that one terrible complete rubbish
not as bad as the other one but been we
going to unravel all these secrets the
return of the world's biggest gut health
expert Professor Tim Spectre he's an
award-winning scientist bestselling
author and he's co-founder of the
company Zoe the home kit for
personalized nutrition everything I'm
about throughout you has a whole
industry of people behind it the first
one is protein
supplements protein is massively hyped
most people are having nearly twice as
much protein in their diets as they need
and most of it will be converted to
sugars and fat coffee it's definitely a
health food and you'll live longer
mouthwash you're more prone to infection
and actually worse smelling breath long
term really yes no hard data that you
should be drinking eight glasses of
water a day 10 minutes in the sun will
get you all the vitamin D you need and
there's some actual data showing that if
you got too much excess fat on your body
exercise alone is a terrible way to deal
with it you need something radical you
and many others like you are a victim of
marketing but we are in a fiber crisis
we think only about one in 20 people are
getting enough fiber for good health as
a dramatic effect on avoiding cancers
mental health and your longevity so you
brought this yep that's the magic potion
a handful of that you reduce your risk
of death by 14 15% two handfuls of 30%
and it's incredibly easy to do
[Music]
so Tim what is the um benefit to me if I
change the way that I'm eating and start
thinking through the lens of my gut
microbiome and start taking the advice
that you talk about in your books what
is the benefit to both me and Society in
terms of statistical like outcomes like
why does it matter
it matters because we are suffering an
epidemic of common chronic diseases so
we're getting increases in cancer heart
disease diabetes
obesity we you know uh majority of the
population are overweight or obese that
has enormous
consequences also on our economic output
um it costs the country and the taxpayer
nearly 60 billion pounds a year as a
country we don't want someone like you
to become unhealthy and so that it's
difficult for you to work you're not
functioning properly the state then has
to provide for you extra healthare Etc
there's that individual level but also
we don't want you to get mental health
diseases
depression uh anxiety all these things
that we know are also linked to poor
diet as well as increased cancers and
and other elements of it so it's it's a
combination of the medical uh the mental
the social the economic all these things
are related to having good nutrition and
I think we've taking it for granted that
it doesn't really matter what we eat
it's all about weight and these things
but that's maybe only the small side of
it I think there's much more to it than
that someone like me I'm you know 30ish
years old and I'm I like to think that
I'm in good shape I exercise every day
um very active so sometimes I think I
can fall into the Trap of think because
there's no obvious sign of disease in me
that I can eat what I want because I'm
working out and then I I sat here with a
doctor a couple of couple of months ago
and he said a sentence to me that
sounded something like we can see
disease growing in you decades out that
really made me change my thinking on
health because if it is like a seed of
health or a seed of disease that's
growing in me irrespective of my current
physical abilities and my you know think
I'm in good
shape it's kind of like compounding
invisibly inside of me disease For
Better or For Worse and that means that
even someone like me I can I can stop
50-year-old Steve's disease now at 30 by
making nudging my health in a slightly
different direction in terms of
nutrition is that an accurate assessment
of because there'll be people that are
listening that are so healthy apparently
healthy on the outside because they can
run fast or because they haven't got any
problems with their bones or
back yeah well when I was your Ed I
didn't think at all about my nutrition
really um you know although I was
trained doctor Etc I said I don't want
too much fat I want this and you know
I'll try and get a nice looking steak
rather than the cheapest one um but I I
I didn't think in that way that I wanted
to look after my health in 20 years time
it's a tough concept for people who are
you know doing so much else and still
feeling good that you know still getting
out of bed fresh in the morning
energized
and not really feeling the effects of of
Aging so I think it's true but it's
quite a tough concept to sell to the
whole population particularly people in
their 20s and 30s about the
future and that's why I think uh
focusing on things like mental health do
resonate perhaps more than saying um
think about what you're going to be like
when you're 50 to most people I've spent
definitely the last 10 years of my life
believing that in order to grow big
muscles which has been an aim of
throughout my life I need to have
protein
supplements what do you think about that
I still have protein supplements in my
house protein powders come home from the
gym big scoop of protein drink it what
do you think of that protein is
massively
hyped there are very few people who are
protein deficient in this country and
need supplements there are a few but I I
would say it's less than 5% of the
population are not getting sufficient
protein to perform either their normal
activities or like you build muscle
because it's so inherent in our normal
food we we evolved you know to be
omnivores and to get enough protein and
our ancestors didn't fall apart because
we didn't get protein
shakes and I think the the fact that
we're focusing on protein is you're you
and many others like you are a victim of
marketing that everywhere you look at
the moment protein is the thing that
sells products if it's got protein on
the pack it's you know that's Ring oh I
need extra protein and protein has this
uh ring of only good about it there's
nothing bad about protein it's like just
going to get me big and strong and I
don't to worry about calories or getting
fat you know I use it or lose it and
that's fine and it's completely wrong
the all the evidence is that um most
people are having nearly twice as much
protein in their in their diets as they
need for normal uh protein balance and
the only people that really need to
worry are if you're um elderly and
you're not eating very much okay so
young people generally yourself will be
getting enough food that a percentage of
all that food is going to contain
protein there's very few foods that
don't contain protein uh people don't
think about it but every time you're
eating pasta or grains you're eating
protein um it doesn't have to be steak
or
eggs and but the elderly if you're not
eating you gone off your food you're
sick you've got you know on some
medication uh might need some extra
protein sources or to focus on it or if
you're a strict vegetarian or vegan in
that position where you're not eating
much or you're sick or you're elderly
then those people do need something now
if you are a
bodybuilder and again you're you're
trying to lose weight at the same
time then you might need some protein
supplements but if you're eating a
normal diet there's no evidence the vast
majority of of people need any extra
protein they can get it all from normal
food and normal food in my opinion is a
much better way of getting it because
that's how our bodies have evolved
rather than getting in a drink or a
supplement or a powder where it's often
mixed with other chemicals it's not in
its natural form we're not sure that
it's all used and the excess protein you
have isn't for
free protein gets broken down and it
either gets eliminated in your body or
it's stored as fat um as it gets
converted to uh sugars and then to fats
so people think of protein as in muscle
and if it's not going to my muscle I
just pee it out it doesn't matter not
the case if you're having lots of
protein that you you can't use up in
your muscles because you already got so
much on board you can't store it
anywhere it uh some of it gets
eliminated but most of it will be
converted to sugars and fat this goes
against everything they told me because
I thought that you could have as much
protein as you like your body can't
store it so I must just be like pooping
out or something I don't know um can't
store it as protein okay but it gets
converted it's broken down into small
pieces and that gets stored in your body
uh for the future so how much protein
can I process in like a day how how many
grams of protein how many kilos roughly
you we but oh 90 say 91 because there's
people
listening it's all muscle
though um so around roughly that amount
of protein
um uh because it goes with weight the
more your weight is the more protein you
need to repair your muscles and and keep
it going so uh the official amount is
normally around you know
0.8 uh grams per kilogram okay okay so
but if we think you know we want to be
on the safe side so most people are 95%
of people that's the uh a safe level but
most people uh in this country are
having like
1.4 um grams per kilogram so they'd be
having uh for you over a 100 grams of
protein
and basically if if you don't anything
extra so you might do a little workout
that might increase it a little bit
maybe 10% so you might be able to use uh
10% there if you're doing a lot of
weightlifting Etc um but not huge
amounts so if you took
300 uh grams of protein most of it is
just going to be either you you'd be
getting rid of it excreting it in some
way or it would be uh converted into uh
sugars and fats stat I found here the
average daily intake of protein in the
UK is 76 gr per day for adults aged 19
to
64 and 67 gram a day for adults aged 65
years and over so that's how much on
average people are consuming with their
normal diets yeah so it's just o roughly
depending on the size of people it's
just over a gram per kilo and they're
getting that without protein most of
them without protein powders just from
their normal diets I mean as an example
my you know my normal breakfast gives me
I worked out you know over 30 grams of
protein um which is sort of what you
want to Kickstart the day
uh in order to get muscles repairing
things but if I took you know an extra
protein powder give me an extra 100
grams that really wouldn't have any
effect at all other than slightly
increasing my weight what about fiber
I've got two questions here what is
fiber in the most simple terms
and is it why is it important and are we
consuming enough fiber in our natural
diets in the UK
so unlike protein where 95% of people
are absolutely fine and not deficient in
protein 95% of people are deficient in
fiber we think only about one in 20
people are getting enough fiber for for
good health so this is this is the
imbalance between the marketing people
just don't make money on fiber like they
do on protein so all the Commerce is
going to everyone's protein deficient
you got to have protein protein protein
protein you know who's supporting the
spinach or the the um the fiber people
hardly anybody we're massively deficient
in it it is the bits of carbohydrates so
carbohydrates are made up of sugar
starches and fibers so fibers are the
parts of carbohydrates that are
not broken down absorbed early on in the
system so they go through to the deeper
parts of the intestine they meat the
microbes and they have to be digested
much slower much lower down your system
and they food for your gut microbes and
it could be soluble ones there been
insoluble ones they're just different
degrees of how hard it is to break it
down and we used to think of it is
ruffage it used to be called ruffage
when I was a a medical student and a
junior doctor you used to eat this stuff
and it was just a like clear out the
toxins it was just like you have this
stuff it scrapes your pipes and cleans
it up up and that's all it was thought
to do but now we we know it's absolutely
crucial for health the average in the UK
is about 20 gram of fiber so if you just
increase that by a
quarter not very much five grams that's
uh uh you know a handful of nuts or
seeds or something a day you will
increase uh or you reduce your risk of
death by 14
15% and if you did two handfuls of nuts
30% it each one it goes up so has a
dramatic effect on your uh
longevity and it's also important for
avoiding cancers and mental health and
nearly everything that we've looked at
so it's really the Forgotten element of
our of our diet that I think at the
moment we're you know in a fiber crisis
we're certainly not in a protein crisis
and yet everyone's talking about protein
it's really it's really a fascinating
interplay between you know what the real
problems are and what the marketing and
and the Commerce of this whole field is
so we need to improve everybody's fiber
amounts all the healthy countries in the
world are eating much more fiber and
it's also diverse fiber it's lots of
different things it's not just having
kale when you came on the podcast last
time you said something which I found to
be quite daunting which was this idea of
trying to get
30 plants into my diet a week you've
brought some food with you today for me
that you say can help me with this Jack
could you grab the food that Tim brought
with him today so you brought this jar
of what looks like a bunch of nuts and
seeds yep that's the magic potion magic
potion tell me more so this is what I
call my diversity jar so um do have a
nibble but basically there's about 10
different types of nut and Seed in there
that each time I see some packet of
mixed nuts or I find something new in a
in a shop I add it to that jar and I
keep it full mix it around and that's
what I throw on my yogurt and cfir in
the morning or I would put on my salad
uh at lunch and that basically is a a
hack that instantly gets me 10 plants
for my week so you're saying how hard it
is to get to 30 plants well just by
doing that you've got uh you've only got
20 to go say see you're a third of the
way just by having a few hacks like that
which incidentally also gives you your
protein okay so rather than your protein
shakes and your whatever handful of that
um you've got you know significant
amounts of of protein but the important
thing for this is the 30 plants people
forget that that a plant doesn't have to
be doesn't look like spinach or kale it
can be a nut and a seed which are so
nutrient dense and so useful that they
will keep whole colonies of hundreds or
thou thousands of different microbes
happy in your gut munching on the
different chemicals in there and they're
very high in fiber very high in protein
I was going to say about the fiber thing
this is a this is a way to get the fiber
as well absolutely yes so they're high
high fiber and high protein and that's
why they are are so nutritious and why
if you're having this sort of stuff you
really don't need uh chemical
supplements and so that that's a that's
just one of several hacks about how you
can add these to your Foods very easily
as well as you know mentally just
thinking I want to try and
find add different things to my my meal
I don't want to have the same meal every
single day people get stuck going to you
know their local uh sandwich shop and
saying I'm only having that prawn salad
prawn salad prawn salad you know just
think every day go something different
and if people start thinking differently
about food not only does it excite the
taste buds a bit more and gets you out
of your rut but it's also going to
generate many more microbes so you know
if you're going to beat me you need to
be getting more diversity in there to to
grow more species so that you can uh you
know keep them all happy and they they
live you know they live off diversity
and variety just as we humans do so when
I got my Zoe results back I one of the
the PDF shows all the bugs in my stomach
is that what you call them bugs I'm you
have more technical bugs or mic microbes
let's call them microbes then uh just
because it makes me sound smarter so all
the microbes in my in my belly and I had
a very narrow group of microbes now if I
you're telling me that if I expand that
collection of microbes My overall health
will be better I'll process my food
better my mental health will be better
is there anything I'm I'm missing from
that list your immune Health would be
better so okay immunity would be better
so you'd get less food allergies you'd
get um uh resistance to infection would
be better so how do I bring I know this
sounds like super stupid question to ask
but I looked at that list and thought
okay so I almost thought of it like
little pets living inside
me um the where do these where do I get
the new pets
from like the new animals from to put
inside my body because I I was thinking
my girlfriend's got loads of them I'll
just kiss
her yes well well you could kiss your
girlfriend and there is quite a lot of
swapping between partners by the way in
microbes so you're not wrong there MH
but unless they had something to eat
they die off okay so what you're doing
is um you know we are continually
surrounded by many of these microbes we
are swapping uh microbes with all our
close friends and family all the time
but unless you've got the fertilizer in
you they're not going to survive and the
fertilizer is diversity of foods yes and
you may have and you know you've kissed
your girlfriend You' got some of her
microbes and they're just sitting there
waiting for to be fed right they might
be in a very dormant State many of these
microbes can go into Spore formation and
stay there for years doing nothing in
tiny amounts they only wake up when you
know Peanut hits them on the head or
something and says oh you know Steven's
give me some food at last you know this
I can eat this I couldn't eat the other
I can't eat nandos I'm going for this so
that's the concept that you want to give
them this rich soil so that they can
flourish and you can gain microbes from
going to other countries you know eating
a variety of foods and there are
microbes that live on a lot of fresh
produce uh that you can get you get them
from dogs uh animals um just by having a
pet around the house or going to the
countryside you can get more microbes in
you but it's it's a lot of them are
actually inside us waiting and places
like our appendix may may be sources of
tiny amounts of these microbes that are
just waiting you know for the right
signal to wake up I think this is
fascinating I looked at the back end of
our YouTube channel and it says that
since this channel started
69.9% of you that watch it frequently
haven't yet hit the Subscribe button so
I have a favor to ask you if you've ever
watched this Channel and enjoyed the
content if you're enjoying this episode
right now please could I ask a small
favor please hit the Subscribe button
helps this channel more than I can
explain and I promise if you do that to
return the favor we will make the show
better and better and better and better
and better that's the promise I'm
willing to make you if you hit the
Subscribe button do we have a deal I
after our last conversation was always
going through the supermarket trying to
figure out what's fermented and what's
not how do I know what's fermented what
does fermented even mean um and you
brought this
array of things with you to show me how
easy it is to ferment things in your own
home I guess yeah I think people are
frightened by
fermentation and it's important to know
what it is and what It Isn't So
fermentation is a word lots of different
meanings but it's when food is modified
by microbes to produce something that is
taste different taste better and is also
healthy for you and in a way it's a
probiotic food because what we're doing
is we're taking basic Whole Foods and we
are adding something like salt or sugar
and that then allows
natural uh microbes on those plants to
flourish and change the composition of
that that food so they make it acidic
they get rid of all the bad bugs and
make it into something super healthy and
all the microbes are growing just like
they would be in your gut if you fed
them so it's like a a mini version of
your gut is what we're seeing here um
and it's incredibly easy to do so that's
why I brought this stuff along so that
we I can demonstrate not only how to get
extra plants into your 30 a week but
also if those plants are fermented they
have many more times more nutrients in
them and the fact that those bugs have
been working on them means they've been
in a way PR digested before they get
into your gut and all these studies are
showing these are super good for all
aspects of your health and if you can
have uh several portions of these a day
you'll really notice the difference so
for people that are just listening on
audio and can't see what have we got in
front of you here so we've got uh a jar
uh like a like a one liter jar of which
is full of uh chopped veg from the
bottom of my fridge all of us would have
fridges like this where you got odds and
ends left behind and the idea is that
you should rather than throwing it away
you can actually just chop it up and
ferment it and stick it in a jar and
there is I can see cabbage I can see a
radish in there it's just like the the
waste veg that most people would
probably Chuck in a bin exactly so a few
years ago I just thrown this in the bin
I wouldn't have thought about doing it
so you you throw it out people have
heard about sakra which is basically
just um fermented
cabbage and you might have heard of
kimchi which is the Korean version which
has just got a few more things in it
like chilies and ginger and
spices uh and this is a sort of mixture
of all of them but it's just to
illustrate the fact that you can ferment
virtually all plants and avoid the waste
and that's what our ancestors did before
fridges because what all you need to do
is uh put them in a jar and squash them
down and add 2% salt and a little bit of
water to cover it that's all you do and
I I can just demonstrate that now for
you if you like so we've got all these
in here and the idea is you um add some
add the salt so we're adding 2% salt
this is really important to measure it
so this that's the only thing really
tricky is to make sure that you've got
uh 2% salt and that gets poured in there
and you you would mix it around I would
normally put it in a big bowl and do it
but uh you you get the idea here you you
you put the salt in you mix it around
and you scrunch it down really hard so
you know like um really getting rid of
any space for air the microbes don't
like air the ones that ferment they call
Anor robic they don't like oxygen and so
they grow really well when you cut out
the oxygen and they can just um live off
start eating the sugars in in the in
these plants and the salt gives them a
competitive advantage against nasty
microbes okay so that means that they
can out compete the other guys because
it's suddenly a different environment
and that's what we're doing so you
squash it down and um I'm going to add a
little bit of water here sometimes you
don't need to add hardly any water and
if you add more than a bit just add a
little bit of salt to that water just
enough to cut it cuz the microbes are
naturally in all these plants people
don't realize that they think oh it must
be sterile I've got it from a nice
supermarket in a plastic wrapper um it's
full of microbes and that's normal and
we know that even in garlic for example
even when you cut it there are PS uh 10
20 different types of microb living in
that garlic and once they they sense the
water and the salt they will suddenly
say ah it's good to come out I can out
compete I can grow I can start munching
the the the sugar and then to pack it
down you either use you can use some
Stones some clean Stones what I like to
do is use some leftover waste um so I
get some outside cabbage leaves or
something else from a plant and just put
it down in there squash it and so you
can see that it's now below the water
line MH and I close the
lid and that's basically it and I would
leave that
for a minimum of three days somewhere
room temperature out of the Sun and
you'll start to see bubbles forming and
that's CO2 the microbes are producing
that they're fermenting it that's it
you've got suddenly your own probiotic
fermented food made from your scraps
rather than throwing it out and that's
that's a great example of what you can
do um to really improve your health for
something that cost nothing uh apart
from the price of salt and and that's
one you made earlier yeah this is a
nicer looking one that's uh one I I did
earlier and I'm just going to see you
can see a few bubbles there uh it's it's
just starting to to get going um and uh
you can open it up uh every day or so to
give it a smell and see what's happening
making sure that it's packed down so
that it's all below the water line once
you've done this it once it's fermented
after a week uh you can put it in the
fridge for months oh really so you could
put that in the fridge fridge for month
yeah once it's fermented the it's become
acidic and the pH has dropped below
4.5 no other microbes can live there
only the ones you want you've selected
personally these are your probiotic
microbes that we know are good for your
health and the difference between this
and your probiotic capsule is that
you'll probably get 30 different
microbes here whereas you take your
capsule you might get two or
three so this is why for fermented foods
I think are a real answer to many of our
problems you know the fact that we've
got a rather Western deprived microbiome
these could really help um people like
you want to boost your G got microbiome
and just introducing these fermented
foods into your regular diet and this is
what the Koreans do for example you know
the Japanese do by using fermented
soybeans in nearly all their Foods so
healthiest populations have large
amounts of fermented food in their diets
when you look at the Japanese and the
Koreans do they have better gut
microbiomes than the people in the UK
and the US yes they do and they but
importantly they live much longer and
have much less of our chronic diseases
or they delay those problems by at least
10 years so I think we need to learn
from the the populations that are doing
it right and this is a really
easy uh thing to do and I think it's
it's a great EX exercise in in teaching
because if you think what's going on
it's this is mirroring what's going on
inside your gut if you had that rich
diversity of of plants in there you can
get many microbes to um to to
proliferate and once you start seeing
the bubbles forming and the the the
amazing change in taste and texture that
you're getting you got to remember this
is the difference between a grape and an
amazing uh vintage red wine it's just
the effect of those microbes in the fact
you know on on that grape skin just
changing over time increasing that
complexity and producing chemicals it
all it's basically a of chemistry lesson
when I'm in the supermarket there are
lots of things that now have labels on
them saying that they're great for gut
health or they're low sugar or they're
low fat I brought everything that I
could find in the supermarket that was
making a claim that it was good for me
and I want you to take a look look at it
these are some of the most popular
things that people pick up in the
supermarket that make these claims that
they're low sugar low fat low high
protein great for gut health so the
first one I've got here is acol which
had says it's got vitamin D B6 it's
great for immune support zero added
sugar 0%
fat rich in Vitamin D that Tim Spectre
is definitely
healthy or
not so um
yeah these these claims uh some of these
claims they're allowed to put on the
packet they're very restricted what they
can actually say in terms of health it
can do are date back you know 30 years
and no longer really valid but they they
have to do it because they're not
allowed to even mention the word
probiotic on a on a packet interestingly
so they're trying to attract you in with
things that would resonate with the
consumer so they do these massive
surveys to saying what's going to
resonate with you Steve when you go into
sh all and you say oh
what's going to what's going to make me
buy this rather than one of the other
ones and so vitamin D we've been
flogging vitamin D for forever you know
10 minutes in the sun will get you all
the vitamin D you need um and it's in
most Foods anyway you don't really need
it in addition in these things uh %
added sugar and % added fat mean that
it's highly processed so the combination
of Health what we call Health Halos um
saying it's super
healthy with Rich in this vitamin no
sugar no fat um is very oldfashioned
science No One Believes that that zero
fat is any good for you anymore and
there's some actual data showing that
lowfat Foods actually uh make you
overeat really yes what does the data
say so when they've comp compared sort
of identical uh meals to people in lab
conditions those eating the lowfat foods
the um high carb but High processed
foods like this will actually overeat
substantially over the next uh day or so
so it's actually making you overeat uh
quite significantly so and there's no
advantage to your body in terms of heart
health by having this because to get
zero fat and make it taste good it's got
to have lots of extra sugars and
starches in there otherwise you you you
just couldn't eat it fat is really
important naturally to make you enjoy
food and so it takes a lot of careful
chemistry to mimic that fat so I would
always avoid anything that said you know
zero sugar zero fat uh rich in vitamins
despite the fact that this probably has
something good probiotics in it m so
you're getting the good probiotics um
it's only one lactobacillus but that's
counteract Ed by all this negative stuff
all these chemicals which we know are
bad for your gut microbiome so that's
not going to be good for you or it's not
going to be good for me either so I
would avoid that one always go for any
yogurt that really has minimum contents
just milk and microbes that's all you
need can you bring me the bin this is
going in the bin going I just
drop in the bin I did scan it on the Zoe
app as well and my relationship to it
was about
35 which is not which is not a health
food which is not a health food what
about this this is definitely healthy Dr
Tim Spectre
Activia deliciously good for your gut
health okay so I know this one's going
to be good
um what else does it say we believe that
a happy gut is a happy you when you love
your gut it loves you back it sounds
like you wrote
it what else what other claims does it
make we ferment our unique blend of five
active strain strains for up to eight
hours so every little pot is packed with
billions of live
cultures loving the planet to love our
gut Activia great for the gut healthy
well so far you know everything looks
everything looks good doesn't it um but
let's have a look and say what extra
things they've added to it um which is
always hard to find in packets and you
you often need a microscope to see them
um so for for it to be good it just
needs microbes and milk and that makes
yogurt you just change the temperature
that's what you get so here we've got um
lots of we've got lots of ingredients
we've got flavorings we've got
concentrates we've got a bit of carrot
for some reason we've got lemon juice
we've got
stabilizers uh we've got tapioca starch
we've got sugars and it claims to have
strawberries although when they last
were picked from the earth I'm not quite
sure so um it's not as bad as the other
one but basically we're we're looking at
a a highly processed product that has
many chemicals you don't really want in
your gut because they will counteract
the good effect of the gut microbes
slightly better than the other one but I
would still not eat it myself self okay
and the fact that it's processed does
the fact that it's processed alone make
it a bad food or is it because the
process of
processing causes a loss in the good
stuff and addition of a lot of bad stuff
when we say Pro because this word
processed foods has become just like a
blanket term so in my brain I go if it's
processed it has to be bad but is that
accurate well we need to separate
virtually all the food that we eat and I
eat as well is processed yeah but um we
need to separate that from Ultra
processed so plain yogurt nothing added
nothing you know changed is processed
because you're mixing a basic ingredient
milk with microbes you're actually
creating something that's processing but
it's when you take it to the next stage
and you would make that same product
from say milk
powder uh and then you would add various
starches and stabilizes emulsifies
concentrates artificial sweeteners
flavorings that same yogurt becomes ultr
processed and it's that extra step that
is the main problem nothing wrong with
processed food you know cheese is
processed there's nothing wrong with
that most of the foods we we eat or some
have had salt added or oil added or
something like that but it's when it's
chem chemicals that you don't find in
your kitchen being added to to foods
that have
been stripped of all their goodness so
they wouldn't just use cow's milk it
would be you know dried extract of casin
or um you wouldn't take wheat it would
be the uh stripped out inner part of
that wheat and then that's temperature
treated to melt it and and change its
composition and to put these things back
together you need all these glues
like these emulsifiers uh you need
stabilizers you need um uh flavoring
sweeteners colorance all these extra
things to make it look like food again
so I think we shouldn't be calling ultr
processed food food that's a
misnomer uh we should call them you know
edible food like
substances that are industrially made
and if we start to realize the
difference between these we can start to
make smart food choices we now know that
many these ingredients there's been lots
of even research since we last talked
about um first things like a spart has
come out as which is an artificial
sweetener has been linked to many health
problems including increased risk of
cancers and uh heart disease we've got
emulsifiers have come out uh recently in
a number of studies to show that they
affect mental health and they also
affect heart disease even when you
adjust for the whole diet and you take
just that component of the food so we
know that ultr processed foods are
probably the worst things we're doing
for our diets and then in the
UK uh the average person is saying about
60% of all their food is ultr processed
without knowing about it we're eating
four times more than uh healthy European
countries who are often poorer than us
so it's not just a question of money
it's just become this battle of of us
poor consumers against these massive
companies with billions of pounds to
spend on marketing that have told us
this stuff is healthy because of these
fake Health Halos vitamins you know no
sugar no this no fat confusing the
consumer and all the time giving us
foods that not only make give us disease
but importantly make us overeat so we we
pick that stuff doesn't matter it's says
just whe even if it's just low fat or
it's got lots of other chemicals both
make you overeat by a quarter so you'll
be hungrier after eating that than you
would be if you had a completely plain
yogurt with none of those extra
chemicals in it
okay so I've got three different drink
like Foods here I've got my Oasis Citrus
punch um on this one it says natural
flavorings and real real fruit so that
must be healthy real fruit if it says
real fruit on it you should be very
suspicious okay that's the first thing
to to look at it uh and natural flavors
that really means nothing and this
is uh natural is a great word means
nothing uh medically scientifically but
it's been a a buzz word for me getting
people to buy stuff so basically this is
a a mixed blend of citrus fruits which
means the mixtures of all kinds of
different uh fruit extract that's
combined with sugar and artificial
sweeners they're again highly processed
fruits they're not fresh fruits and it's
got a mixture of those uh it's got
citric acid it's got sugar orange
flavorings uh it's got stabilizers
polyphosphates glycerol Esters uh it's
got um looks like wood resins um acidity
Regulators uh preservatives it's got
some potassium sorbate potassium
benzoate it's got the sweeteners
aspartame and uh a es spot is what
you're just talking about right yes
that's the one that who have just put on
their uh warning list um so yes it's
it's packed with things that you
wouldn't expect if you just squeezed a
bit of juice
uh in and thought it was healthy so this
is a good example of um a totally fake
Ultra processed food that makes it look
like it's real fruit and it's going to
be healthy for you and it is just a mix
of chemicals that's just going to mess
up your gut microbes and make you feel
hungrier okay but this one here this
Philadelphia says light so it says 100%
of The Taste but 40% less fat so
Philadelphia
light surely
that's good well it's it's got cheese in
it it's often have this we did do some
tests on this a while ago it does have
microbes in it if it's low in fat
they've generally added something else
to increase the mouth feel and indeed we
see here it's got stabilizers it's got
emulsifiers uh all these things that we
know uh have effects on your gut
microbes make you hungrier and can
affect your heart as well so yeah I I
would avoid that one what do we have to
I've got a few last things for you there
what do we have to look out for on the
packaging of these products because
interestingly the one you have in your
hand the bar there the snack bar on the
back of it they do admit that it's a
little bit processed they actually
there's a sentence on the back of it
I'll read read out says um I was reading
it as you said it it says well um well
clearly it would be wrong for us to
claim that everything in this bar is
100% natural and simply grows on trees
obviously some ingredients need to to be
cleaned dried and roasted too and
therefore to some extent processed it's
just that we believe the less we mess
with it the better it tastes that's why
we never add any artificial flavors or
colors or any
preservatives yeah natural bar and the
ingredients you know that's a good thing
to say it's quite hard to produce some
of these snack bars without having
things to stick it together or gums
glucose syrup soy protein
Crispies isolate tapioca starch salt
dates almonds salt salted caramel moso
sugar buttermilk powder natural
flavorings cream powder milk rice flour
carbo flour and
salt yeah it doesn't when you read it
out like that it doesn't sound quite as
natural as the uh label suggests does it
because you just got all these
ingredients that are you know again half
of them you wouldn't find in your in
your kitchen
um and it's partly to to you know
protein packed um you know if it was if
you just need the nuts and the seeds you
wouldn't have to add in all this uh
other stuff from soy and and other beans
and things which are ultr processed
they're just taking that bit of it
combining it together so some of these
are better than others um but um again
this is ultr processed and you know
these all these snacks
interestingly are really often the
downfall in in in places like the US and
the UK where we're just eating so many
so much our our our energy is coming
from these snacks which wasn't the case
20 years ago so on that point of
snacking is snacking good or bad and
what impact does that have on the
overall nutritional um profile of an
individual because a lot of people snack
right nearly everybody snacks I think
that's right over 90% of people snack so
it's become normal to snack in this in
this country in the US it is the norm
it's not the norm in other countries so
you see much less snacking habits in
southern Europe uh than you do here and
much less in uh many Asian countries as
well a Zoe study found that 95% of
people were
snackers yes and 25% of people are
undoing the benefits of healthy meals by
unhealthy snacking yeah so 95% of people
we found in that Zoe study as are
snackers and most of them are unhealthy
so just by reaching for a snack unless
you're really careful you're going to be
having not only
extra calories but unhealthy calories
that's going to undo many of the good
things you're you're eating so we found
in the Zoe survey that people would be
really focusing on their main meal
saying this is a really healthy meal I'm
having plenty of plants and veget but oh
well I've got to have my snack and so
they'd be undoing all that good by
having something that would
then a couple of hours later really
upset um their metabolism and make them
hungrier and so mess up the the idea and
make them hungrier so we in the UK and
the US it's around a quarter of our
calories come from snacks if we were
able to even to reduce that a bit or
just change that snack to a healthy one
or ideally move that snacking time to
the meal itself most of these would be
much less harmful if you had them at the
end of your
meal when your body is you know starting
to do all this work breaking down the
food is gearing up for this High
activity virtually all the snacks that
people have late in the evening are bad
for
you and that's because you're getting a
sugar Spike just before going to bed
your body's not ready for it your gut
microbes are not ready for it it doesn't
give them a rest and so you actually end
up hungrier the next day so we're
starting to realize that it's not just
the food and we've seen that most these
snacks are very unhealthy going to make
you hungrier but the timing of it also
messes up your Cadian rhythms so you're
not recovering and the next day you're
going to feel hungrier than you were if
you didn't snack so it's like
counterintuitive you think oh if I have
something before going to bed I'm not
going to be as hungry tomorrow and this
is what many people get into this this
common mistake AK so we need to start
changing people's attitude uh in in in
this snack epidemic about snacks and say
you know you don't need them um and if
you do have healthy ones and you know
nuts and seeds and fruit are perfectly
healthy ones and we showed in our in our
study which we published recently that
people who do have those healthy snacks
are really hardly any extra risk of
health problems um compared to those
that people don't snack as long as it's
not late at night so if you eat within
that sort of normal eating window and
you you know some people are natural
snackers I don't know if I'm not but I
know many of my colleagues at Zoe uh
can't go two or three hours without
eating they really find it hard and but
just by thinking more about that snack
and saying well I'm going to I I know
I've got this tendency I'm going to eat
something that's healthy like nuts or
something yeah just a handful of mixed
nuts an apple a pear um something that's
not super sugary or super fat but
importantly not ultr processed not
something that's got this health Halo
that says eat me I've got high in
protein I'm going to you know eat me and
you'll get bigger muscles uh no eat me
and you'll get fatter those Health Halos
then what are just so we've summarized
them low fat is a health Halo you're
were saying no sugar real fruit trying
to remember all the ones um extra
vitamins vitamin labeling on on products
um natural flavorings I think it said
yes one of the products those are those
the main ones have I missed any there I
think we've covered yeah so claims about
low fat low sugar uh nothing artificial
high protein I guess natural right uh
high protein um some would be gut
friendly um generally they warning signs
that this food is to be avoided find
something that doesn't need that Health
claim you never see a whole real food
with a health claim they don't need it
you got an apple doesn't need a claim
you know contains vitamins contains uh
fiber real foods don't need health
labels I've had a confused relationship
with
bread I I look at bread all bread I
think that's bad this is cheating on my
microbiome
is that the truth is bread
bad most bread is bad most Supermarket
bread is ultr processed sugar and
contains many other chemicals you don't
really want in you makes you hungrier
and the general perception of the public
is it's a healthy food I found this
myself when I started doing my glucose
levels even Brown breads were all over
the place there are some breads that I
can eat in small amounts that are still
healthy
things like Rye Breads and if it's
sourdough that also improves it but I
think in general we're eating far too
much bread for most people there might
be some people who can support it and
that's why it's good to test your
glucose responses to It But most bread
has too much sugar not enough fiber too
many uh chemicals in it and uh we should
be looking to other things for our
nutrition have it as a rare treat have
it just when you go to a restaurant or
whatever but for most people you know
it's it's a real red flag for me the
other red flag that shocked me was my
relationship with white rice because I'd
grown up eating white rice and I thought
white rice was a great thing to have
after I'd been to the gym with some
chicken so I I used to whenever I saw
white rice I thought it was great and
then I looked on Zoe and I had a 15 out
of 100 relationship with white rice and
I think my girlfriend had a five out of
100 relationship with white rice so I no
longer have white rice I've swapped it
out for uh I think quinoa is usually
what we have in the house now nearly any
grain is better than right white rice
it's got more fiber it's got more
protein in it it's got more nutrients in
it and rice is the most overrated food I
think even more so than bread because
yeah people think it's healthier than
you know having potatoes or pasta they
associate it with healthy things because
often sometimes the rest of the meal is
actually quite good MH and you know
vegetable cures or whatever it is often
quite healthy but the rice itself is
really just sugar and there's there's no
have it as a rare treat but so many
other grains you can have instead quinoa
barley oats um uh you know or even
putting in lentils or legumes you know
beans instead of that Rice just makes it
so much healthier quick one I discovered
a product which has changed my life
called Eight sleep this product eight
sleep which are a sponsor of this
podcast has been a revelation in my life
because the eight sleep pod cover which
is basically fitted sheet that goes over
your mattress controls the temperature
of your bed throughout the night and it
follows Nature's natural Rhythm it
starts cool gets colder while you go
into different phases of sleep and then
heats up slightly as you wake up in the
morning which is effectively guiding you
to have a deeper more restorative sleep
go to 8sleep.com which is EIG ght
sleep.com
Steven and if you do that you'll save
$150 on the Pod cover that I have on my
bed the one I'm talking about grab your
pod cover send me a DM and let me know
how you get on when you talk about your
habits being so important I when you're
eating and what you're eating and making
sure that you carve out time to have
your meals because I was telling you
earlier I think before we started
recording that I'm in a bit of a pattern
at the moment of eating my first meal of
the day at like 400 p.m. or 5:00 p.m.
because if I'm recording podcast or I'm
doing something in the media or on TV I
didn't like to eat before then um what
is an example of great food habits I
want to know what what your food habits
are on a perfect day say you know this
was your 10 out of 10 day when would you
eat how many meals would you eat and
what times would would and wouldn't you
eat okay so like you I have very busy
days where sometimes it goes out the
window and I think we got to realize
that you got to try this sort of 8020
ideal you know you're trying to stick to
something 80% of the time knowing that
20% it's out of your control don't worry
about it it and if you do that you can
do that sustainably for decades right
it's the people who obsessed and say I
mustn't break it and if you've broken it
one day okay end end of my brilliant
experiment that's DFT so if I'm at home
for example working at home I'm in
control of things I will not eat
anything before 11:00 I will have a
black coffee because I know um that
wakes me up and I like it and it's also
good for me but I would have anything
else until 11:00 I'll go down and I fix
myself my bowl of uh full fat uh yogurt
and I'd put my diversity jar sprinkled
in there and I'd see what else is in the
fridge so I might have some berries if
they're around at the moment plenty of
seasonal berries might get some from the
freezer if uh we're in the mid you know
we're in March or something there's no
no fresh berries uh or I might just chop
up an apple and put it in there I'm
getting my protein
I'm getting uh fat you know I'm not
feeling hungry uh and having a dip in
energy in the middle of the day that I I
would probably have if I hadn't eat
anything you said coffee I have my
coffee because I know it's good for me
last time we spoke you were kind of on
the fence about coffee you two trains of
thought about whether it's good for us
or not you're now saying you think it's
good for us yeah well I must have given
the wrong impression to you but coffee
is definitely a health food interesting
okay um there are some people who don't
tolerate it very well they don't
tolerate the caffeine a few percent of
people but even if you have deaf coffee
it's decent quality because there's
different ways of taking the the
caffeine out all the studies are now
showing consistently that uh you will
have less heart disease and you'll live
longer if you uh drink coffee and uh
having sort of between one and four cups
of coffee a day that seems to be the
Sweet Spot bit more than that you
probably got some problem you know that
coffee is actually a fermented
plant so people don't think of it that
way think oh it just comes in a jar you
know I don't need to worry about it but
actually you know it comes off a a tree
you get this pod this Bean um you take
it off you break it up it then gets
fermented on the floor of usually you
know wherever it is in Africa or Asia
where where it is and it's humid the
microbes are working on it breaking it
down then you go and dry it and uh roast
it and that ends up being the coffee we
have so the mics are playing a role in
that it's also a source of fiber so
three cups of coffee gives you around
five grams of fiber which is about a
quarter of your uh the average UK or us
amount
so you know it's not the main source of
fiber but it all helps and in the us
it's often the main source of fiber uh
that they get so polyphenols the fiber
um also for many people it gets them
awake and alert has that effect of
stopping tness so if you if you're
careful with it you don't overdose on it
and you know it doesn't give you heart
fluctuations it's going to be actually
beneficial for you long term so this is
a great example of a food that we've
totally changed our minds on over the
years initi my first research paper I
ever wrote was that um coffee causes
cancer okay so when I was a I was
actually a medical student and I was
very proud of my paper and this was
great and it was based on very poor
studies done in the 1980s and it was
complete rubbish um so I'm very happy
that to go and correct that mistake and
tell people that you know you should
much better to drink coffee coffee than
say orange
juice and orange juice is tends to be in
the health section and coffee definitely
in the sort of
recreational uh section and they really
should be changed over most orange juice
we have is ultra processed high sugar
very bad for most people coffee is good
for the vast majority of people what
else have you been wrong about what else
have you changed your mind about over
the last couple of years because of the
research that you now have you know the
data you now have access to in the
research that you've
done well I was K to avoid fats for a
long
time um I cut back on cheese because I
thought that's high in saturated fats
that can't be good for you I would have
bought lowfat products
before um and so that most doctors were
indoctrinated with that and many doctors
are still in that mindset that fat is
bad and you know carbs and starch are
good um drinking lots of water was good
for
you and I now having researched it for
the book know there's no hard data that
you should be drinking eight um glasses
of water for example a day which is what
most of the um recommended government
sites tell you and obviously the drinks
industry is very keen to support that
because you know the big companies the
the co the Pepsis have moved into the
water business and they're trying to
sell everyone plastic bottled water
which is terrible for the planet the
idea that uh we're all deprived of
hydration and having all kinds of
problems with it is is really made up
there's no hard evidence at all and if
you look at um doctors who work on
marathons they see that far more people
die or have health problems from over
hydrating in uh the marathon Race then
dehydrating so the human body is really
good at some things you know you think
about our ancestors they kind of knew
when you were thirsty right it's like
hang on this quite a you know and the
idea that oh we've got no idea if we're
thirsty or not um we need to be eating
you know have a stopwatch to tell us to
drink every hour on the hour is
obviously nonsense when you think about
it that's so true my um for my birthday
just gone someone brought me this
massive like
what's the way to describe it barrel
water bottle and it has like eight
liters marked on the side of it and they
said to me when they gave it to me you
need to drink that every day and so the
idea was that I put it on my desk as a
reminder that I need to drink that whole
Barrel before I finish work no I mean
you just think about it well you know
we've been involving for millions of
years and you know you can't live long
without
water um so clearly we got a pretty good
mechanism we've inherited to tell us
when we need to drink water and when we
don't and I I I just think that's uh
again marketing uh concept all the soft
drink the you know all this rehydration
these electrolytes all this stuff it's
it's largely nonsense and it's just you
know again like the protein marketing
idea is that uh and we're very
susceptible to it because we like a a
quick fix or and there'll be a few
people that say I feel better when I
drink lots of water sure you know but
the idea that uh we're so out of control
that you know someone needs to bring us
water every hour uh is madness and that
there is you know there isn't this
variation we got up to your lunch so we
did your breakfast sounded nice your
lunch what time do you typically eat
lunch and what do you typically have on
a 10 out of 10 day where everything's
going to
plan I mean it all varies and you know I
think I don't want to give the idea I'm
always having the same lunch cuz I I do
try and Vary it um but if I'm on my own
working I'm not with friends or whatever
um it would be a fairly quick Affair and
it would probably be a
salad um and I
would get a lettuce or um a grated
cabbage I would throw whatever I have in
the fridge in there and I would add some
protein to it so I would add some beans
I always keep cans of beans around they
cost nothing they're a huge source of
fiber and protein tip those in they
might be lentils they might be um
chickpeas might be standard mixed beans
and um I'd put them in if I had some
cheese I might chop that up might put a
bit of mozzarella in there olive oil um
balsamic vinegar um that' be it and if
I'd had some some sourkraut or something
I might have that on the side a bit of
ferment and I've increasingly recently
since my I've been doing more research
on this I might make my salad dressing
actually with some fermented milk some
kefia and you just mix up the oil in
vinegar and you just at the last minute
add in your uh ferment so you're
actually getting probiotics added to
that that that if I'm on my own and
hurry that's that's probably
what yeah reasonable but it would vary
depending on what I was taking what
fruits what vegetables and yeah I would
have fruit afterwards what kind of fruit
do you do you like I am I noticed on my
Zoe app that bananas rank incredibly low
for me I think my ranking on a banana
out of 100 is 50 now I've been eating
bananas like a monkey I've always
thought bananas were just fantastic so I
thought unlimited bananas were a great
idea until I saw the Zoe app and it said
my score is 50 out of 100 now I've
usased up on the bananas and I'm having
much more berries because I do really
well for red berries in particular in
fact the order that I the Zoya had um
fruits in is raspberries were number one
cherries were number two strawberries
were third then pears then peaches then
apples then kiwis then blueberries then
grapes and then bananas were like 10th
50 out of 100 well I scored him worse
than you you'd be pleased to know um I
used to eat lots of bananas and it was a
thing you just put in your backpack
comes to his own packaging you know you
can have it when you want I thought this
is super healthy cuz I've seen you know
Roger Federer um eat lots of bananas you
know he seemed pretty fit um and that's
way we associated with with the
marketing thing oh lots of potassium you
know must be good for us really lots of
sugar and they're not they're not great
for us uh my score was about 30 or
something so it so I I still have them
occasionally because I you know you know
enjoy them occasionally but I don't have
them every day like I used to so I now
swap them out for peirs we have some
great peirs in this country and they're
always good uh apples and again I'll
have my my berries if if I've if I've
got them so
um and uh kiwi fruits I had to also give
up grapes I used to eat lots of grapes
and I used to love them but get huge
sugar Spike with grapes which I know
then you know would make me hungrier
for the rest of the day so um and I have
them as a a treat you know might have
some grapes once a month that's still
fine so I think we shouldn't never say
I'll never have those again it's just
like what's your staple MH uh what do
you have most of the time should you be
swapping that for something just as
tasty or nice or a mixture of things but
get out of that rut just because someone
told you that you know Banana's good has
pottassium in it and make you play
tennis better you know it was it's that
kind of mindset that we we really need
to change and um and I guess it depends
what else is on the plate I remember
Fredrico who's the head of nutrition at
Zoe um heard telling me
that the plate itself has its overall
score so if I had you know maybe
something that wasn't so good in
isolation but with a couple of other
things that are really high ranking in
terms of health in microbiome then the
overall score comes up and it's really
the average of the whole plate yeah it's
exactly I don't we the idea is we don't
want to demonize one little thing so you
might be obsessed with mayonnaise for
example you know and i' say to you well
you can have a small amount of
mayonnaise if it's going to make you eat
a salad and if that salad is high fiber
nutritious it's got plenty of good
things in it herbs and etc etc etc or
you know a tiny bit of ketchup or
whatever you know I'd still be saying
yeah you can try something else instead
of those but don't get hung up about it
and I
think it's absolutely true that you know
nutrition has gone into this idea of
this this is wrong this gives you cancer
this is this is bad and meat is a great
example of that debate you know people
ask me are you you know are you for meat
are you against meat um and I I've s
changed I flipped on this as the
evidence has changed I'm definitely
against processed Meats ultr processed
Meats which are lowquality stuff put
together in ready meals
Etc you know you'd be much better off
just having mushrooms or or beans
instead of that mixed with it a
vegetarian version of it but real high
quality meat in small
amounts nothing really wrong with it as
long as you have enough space on the
rest of the plate to make up for it what
about the carnivore
diet well I keep getting probably like
you you know people come and say you
know I heard you talking about um you
know not eating plants as bad but I've
been living for two years on the
Carnival D I feel great you know and I
say fine there might be one in 10,000
people uh that can exist with zero fiber
and zero plants and you know there you
know in uh in the near the North Pole
Etc there are people who exist on high
fat and high protein diets they' evolve
for it but vast majority of people will
suffer greatly by
having denuded gut microbiome
and just eating meat is not what our
ancestors did anyway um I've lived with
the hadza tribe for a week and they eat
a lot of vegetables and and and fruits
and berries and nuts and seeds and they
still meat is a treat and three months
of the year they have no meat because
it's hard to catch but they've got all
this other stuff so the idea that it's
natural that's what we did is is really
wrong and some people might feel better
briefly you know there's a difference
between how people respond to uh fats
particularly uh and carbs so you might
lose a bit of weight a lot of that's
actually uh they've done some studies
showing people on high keto high fat
protein diets they'd lose weight quicker
but a lot of it is water oh okay so
they're sort of drying out and in a way
sometimes bodybuilders do that to make
them look more toned but actually long
term they don't lose that uh and it
comes back and the main problem is they
gut microbes are really crying out for
food so you're starving your gut
microbes if you're just on a meaton diet
so there's no evidence that that is
healthy and lots of evidence that lack
of fiber is really bad for you so
remember that statistic we went back to
just a five gram change in fiber so if
these people you know so if the average
uh is 20 grams a day and the carnivore
diet person is on five or less then you
we're talking you know 50% increases in
heart disease and reduced longevity so
you know people do what they want but
the the data absolutely doesn't support
it another thing that I have every day
is chewing gum and I was in the car
because it's in the center console of of
the car that I that I'm driven around in
the D car we call it and there's like
seven different types of chewing gum now
when I eat this chewing gum it's there's
this expl iion of Sweetness in my in the
first couple of bites and I I was
thinking the other day as I was driving
home I was thinking I think I'm becoming
a little bit compulsive like I didn't
need the CH gum for any other reason
then I think there's this it's doing
something in my brain I grab it I put
one in I throw it in the B I grab
another I put I throw it in the bin and
I think I'm just doing it for that Sugar
burst my question is broadly about
chewing gum but are these artificial
sweeteners that exist in the chewing
gums that I'm probably
eating worse than just normal
sugar
they're better for your teeth okay so
you will get less tooth decay Yeah by
having the artificial sweeteners but
most of them will be causing problems to
your gut microbes okay and not your
mouth microbes as well so anything you
mess with in your mouth and your saliva
things like mouthwashes as well these
artificial ones they're all shown to
reduce your natural gut microbes and
actually cause more problems so that
you're more more prone to infections and
actually more prone to get overgrowth of
bad microbes giving you bad breath
so you know you have this initial hit
which you know often the mouthwashes are
similar in a way to that sort of instant
gratification of the chewing gum because
it feels fresh and tangy in your in your
mouth but you're often killing off the
good guys that are protecting your your
your mouth and the worry I have is about
this sweetness is it it's sensitizing
you to want more sweet Foods so it
probably make you hungrier for more carb
foods later in the day MH so I don't
think there's any particularly bad about
chewing gum per se um other than if
people chew a lot of it it's sugary you
know it will give you more uh uh dental
decay but the artificial sweetness are
probably worse because they're having a
negative effect on the gut micro on the
all the microbes from your mouth down to
your gut mouthwash I am a prolific
mouthwash user oh dear I know and
they've done actual studies on this to
show that um you know yes customer
consumers like it you know so like you
probably like that feel of being fresh
and doing something and having a tang in
the mouth a bit like a you know a Tangy
chewing gum as well um a mint or you
know there's something nice in the brain
that says this is good but if you do it
too much you start to de you know
destroy your natural defense mechanism
and microbes in your tongue and your
saliva are there to fight off other bugs
and you're more likely to get um
overgrowth of the wrong ones and you
know you may actually end up having
worse smelling breath long term uh than
if you weren't using these chemicals the
topics I'm about to throw at you are
very complicated and you're very good at
simplifying things so everything I'm
about to throw at you typically has a
whole industry of people behind it that
have over complicated it and are selling
courses about it and different hacks and
tips and tricks if you could I would ask
you just to give me a simple solution to
the things that I'm going to throw at
you the first one is weight
loss there's not a simple solution you
have
to do something that's sustainable for
long periods of time so forget the idea
that it's really important to lose
weight over a few weeks you want
something that can maintain your weight
at a good level for decades and if you
are have a problem
with really excess weight you're uh
extremely obese morbidly
obese um you need something
radical darts are not going to do it you
need one of these new drugs um the uh
gp1s these injections the asmic the wig
ois or you need bariatric surgery
to get you down to that level Something
dramatic for most people what do you
think of those new drugs the asmic and I
think they're amazing really for people
that really need it what about for not
for you not for you well I've got lots
of friends that are in seemingly great
shape that are taking these new weight
loss drugs zix and all that stuff well
they're mad why there are lots of side
effects that
um aren't worth the benefits not the
benefits if you have any minor weight
problems the the benefits outweigh the
risks if you are so obese that your
chance you know your 50/50 chance of
having a heart dise heart attack in the
next or a stroke in the next five years
so people with morbid obesity have a
worse prognosis than people with cancer
so it's you know like I've got cancer
what do I do I'll take a drug I'll
accept that it's got some side effects
but you know I want to live and they do
work for m majority of people for people
who have only
minor uh levels of uh obesity just you
know some love handles or
whatever to cut out your all your
appetite signals in your brain we don't
know what that does long term and we
don't we do know that it has can affect
your pancreas it can uh cause some rare
cancers it can do other stuff to your
digestive system that we still you know
a long way away from knowing so it's
it's a drug for extreme obese problems
that we've created through our
ultrapress foods and people with
terrible diabetes Etc it is not
something for uh the general population
so for for those
people it's firstly improving the
quality of your your diet is number one
so get down from an average of 60% Ultra
processed food to something less than
20%
find a consistent way
to that's that's the first thing to do
and then the next thing is to change
your mindset
about things don't get obsessed with
with calories start thinking about
eating your 30 plants a week because
that will naturally give you all the
fiber and uh change your appetite
signals as well the fitness Community
were quite disgruntled last
time probably disg
again when you said what you said about
calories because a lot of people do rely
on the calories in calories out system
for weight loss yeah well OBD experts
don't so it may be fine in gyms to talk
about that that's old science we now
know that that this calorie model from a
practical point of view is completely
broken because we've been not talking
about the quality of food the structure
of food all these different effects
these interindividual effects that we're
talking about meaning that counting
calories is for vast majority of people
impossible or meaningless so it it's and
it's the the marketing and the companies
who are sign selling us these low
calorie products this idea that it's
really simple all you got to do is x y
and Zed you'll lose weight that's what
we're fighting here and they may have
influenced you know the gyms with their
uh special drinks and programs and
people wanting the crash course of come
in here you'll lose all this you you'll
gain muscle you lose weight you know
it's
easy the evidence is very clear that if
you restrict calories you will lose
weight but 80% of people regain it
pretty quickly and will actually go over
the other end if they haven't changed
their diet in terms of quality and
taking care of what they're eating and
there's good evidence that people that
follow
uh a program where they are not focusing
on calories but they are focusing on
food quality um they're looking at their
sugar Peaks they're looking at their fat
levels they're looking at their gut
microbes they are looking at the time of
day they're eating they're looking at
the how to eat just
thoughtfully and not talking about fat
levels and you
know avoiding all these foods that we've
been talking about they will
consistently lose small amounts of
weight not large amounts but small
consistent amounts that don't make them
more hungry and the key is do things
that don't make you hungrier the reason
calorie restriction doesn't work is our
Evolution tells us to ramp up the
appetite uh the hunger
signal obvious you know it's a same way
if you do exercise it makes you hungrier
we have this inbuilt mechanism that's
why the only drugs that where methods
that work are these drugs like um AIC
wigo that act on the appetite they act
on the brain they just from the gut
sends a signal to the brain switches off
the appetite signal
otherwise you you just reduce calories
or you increase exercise that appetite
signal is just going right up there and
you can carry on resisting it for a
while most people have tried this they
know and it gets harder and harder every
week and then suddenly you crack and
then you say oh I've I've given up now
I'm I'm back and often you swing above
it yo-yo yeah and that and that yo-yoing
is probably the worst thing you can do
because it just makes your you know you
got no consistency on that point of
exercise there was a lot of contention
last time we spoke around the subject
matter of exercise because a lot of
people go out and do cardiovascular
exercise they run on a running machine
in order to try and lose weight but you
and many other people that I've spoken
to have said that that's not a great
strategy for weight
loss yes the lots of Studies have done
and said
people are trying you know to lose
weight conventional by conventional
means we're not talking the Zoe method
but the oldfashioned ways of calorie
restriction or you know changing to keto
diets or whatever it is and if those
people are put on exercise or no
exercise at the same time does it help
them and uh generally it doesn't okay so
um and if you do exercise
Alone um then
there's no evidence as many people gain
weight as lose weight on exercise so you
think why is that well if you think it
through
exercise uh is a and I'm not noex I
exercise every day I love it it's great
for my brain and my heart and everything
else and reduces lots of diseases but
people have got to separate that from
weight loss if we're going to make any
progress here and if you got too much
you know excess fat on your body
exercise alone is a terrible way to deal
with it because you're like saying I'm
not going to deal with my diet I'm just
going to run it off in the gym and keep
taking my supplements and do everything
else and what happens for most people is
that their metabolism slows down the
signals of hunger
increase after exercise
and psychologically people think oh well
I've done some exercise I've burnt off
those calories you know I can have that
donut or whatever and so subconsciously
they're also maybe snacking slightly
more than they would be and that's why
for most people it doesn't work now I
know people got upset last year but some
people it does
work and this is probably there's a
different response we don't all respond
to exercise with appetite signals
exactly the same way but for as many
people it did work there are people that
made them actually
put on weight do you see what I mean
that's why the studies show no
difference so you always find someone
who writes you say Steven this guy's an
idiot because I you know I did this and
I lost uh you know 10 kilos but this you
know exactly someone else will say I did
this and I gained 10 kilos and I thought
I was doing the right thing so the point
is you can't rely on it and it's when
there's something obviously modifiable
like your diet it's so easy we've got so
much choice now and what to eat we're
not forced to eat ultr processed foods
or lowfat this or or whatever you know
we can make those choices we should be
doing that not trying to saying am I
lucky am I that small percentage of
person that can do this purely from
working out more in the
gym supplements you mentioned there
that's the next thing I wanted to ask
you about supplements vitamins
my house used to be stacked with
supplements and then after our
conversation last time round I look at
them most most of them like they've lied
to me like I've been a victim of
marketing of sorts and I've got every
bloody supplement I've got your omega-3
vitamin D electrolytes calcium you name
it it's still in my house mhm what is
your view on these supplements in
general my view hasn't changed at all
that the vast majority of supplements
are completely
worthless but there are some that are
useful for some people some of the time
like
um like there are some people who have
vitamin D deficiency who black people um
yes uh some black people black dark
skinned people living in places with
very low you know if they're living in
Scotland uh and they might have poor
diets they don't have much vitamin D in
it those people could probably do do
with some supplementation over winter
because they produce less vitamin D than
people with lighter skin yes
lighter skin evolved as a mutation uh as
uh humans came out of Africa in order in
order to survive in lower sunlight areas
so naturally uh whiter skinned people
have a they're less protected against
the Sun but they have a better vitamin D
production system so generally darker
skin have more problems so I used to see
many patients uh and often they don't go
in the sun either because cult naturally
uh you know they cover themselves up and
so that that's a problem so there
definitely are people who can take
benefit from taking some of these
vitamin I'm not saying that at all but
the idea that everybody should be taking
them is just Madness uh there's no
evidence that in my field of
osteoporosis that taking vitamin D and
calcium actually prevents uh
osteoporosis or bone disease although
for years and years and years we thought
it did but all the big studies now show
that's not true if you take calcium uh
all the studies are suggesting that not
only does it not have any benefit in
terms of uh bone or muscle Health but it
can adversely affect your heart so
because the calcium you get in in
capsules or supplements you're taking
one big lump of it at a time rather than
getting it in your green vegetables
which would be slowly broken down and
absorbed in your gut in ways that your
body can deal with so so you're getting
this it's like someone injecting it into
your vein is very different to being
slowly given it uh throughout 24 hours
as the way nature intended what what
supplements then could most of us
benefit from
taking if you have a good diet you won't
need any
supplements but most of us don't have a
good diet so so what do you do do you
promote supplements and say don't worry
about your diet which is what the
marketing comp comp want and the vitamin
companies want they want us to forget
the diet keep the ultr processed food
stuff coming keep it all coming guys
this junk food no real Whole Foods no
plants no fruits that's fine you guys
are going to need some vitamins and that
may be true for people on very poor
diets you know only eat beige food maybe
they do need some uh
supplements but I think there's no
evidence however there is very little
evidence that people who do take
supplements are any healthier than
people that don't take supplements so
it's not so you could say people say oh
it's like an insurance policy I'm taking
it this insurance policy therefore
that's a really good reason to take
multivitamins Etc and I've heard that
said even from some epidemiologists and
doctors but to my mind uh just as likely
to do you harm as it is to do you any
good and it definitely is affecting your
wallet what about omega-3 I take that as
well the Trials of that have shown it
doesn't work uh for reducing heart
disease or um any other major disease
unless you've just had a heart
attack alcohol I've just given up
alcohol not really told anybody this but
about two months ago now I decided that
I could see no net positive in my life
there wasn't any sort of social
lubricant which sometimes people say it
as being the reason to drink alcohol so
I gave it up entirely and if and it's
been really an interesting experiment in
giving up alcohol I was one of the
people that sat right on the fence
didn't think I had a bad relationship
with it um didn't have a huge reason to
drink it didn't drink it that often
anyway and then I decided one day I'll
run the experiment of just quitting and
see what it's like and there's been
multiple situations where just out and
about wait waiters who are maybe a
little bit poorly trained have literally
tried to force me to drink alcohol like
one particular waiter was like go on
this is not alcohol this is Art I'm just
going to leave the bottle here right in
front of you if you change your
mind that one particular waiter um and
then all the other social contexts where
you're just like it's just assumed that
you drink what is your stance on
alcohol Well you certainly don't need it
okay so
um most the studies are pretty
consistent say that the more alcohol you
drink the more are your chances of all
kinds of diseases and
problems there
are some exceptions to that that comes
down often to the Mediterranean effect
people who drink a glass or two of red
wine do seem to have less heart
disease but they won't be protected from
other conditions so they won't be
protected you know from cancers or um uh
some Strokes Etc and lifespan is sort of
unclear in that particular group so in
general alcohol is bad for you no no
doubt
but and so if you don't drink I don't
think I would say to you Stephen you're
wrong you need to be start drinking uh
red
wine but for those people who who do
drink or drink occasionally small
amounts well I would say to you is
do there are some drinks that are
healthier than others and red wine is
one that's been shown to reduce by about
30% your risk of heart disease in most
studies and it's not clear absolutely
clearcut but if you drink too much it
actually goes bad again for you so it's
really quite a small
window um and there might be some other
drinks in the future that might be
healthy and this comes back to plants
because when you're drinking wine you're
drinking fermented grapes right so the
alcohol is bad fermented grapes are good
so in the future I'd like to see us
getting LLY zero alcohol wines and they
they are coming and I I I tasted some
from Canada Etc where you can get like a
1% wine that you can't 1% by the way is
what in kombuchas you can't metabolize
you don't notice it and if they have all
those benefits they could be that new
era of actually healthy alcohols and
there might be some ciders as well
because they've got the skin of the
Apple but virally all the other alcohols
uh have no real uh health benefit what
about sleep and the gut
microbiome I've I've wondered if there
was a connection between how well I
sleep sleep has become this Obsession in
my life I I feel like I'm a competitive
sleeper now I really enjoy the process
I've seen the variance in a well slept
night and a poorly slept night on how on
my mood um how I perform how I'm how my
brain works what does the research say
about the role that sleep plays on our
gut microbiome and on our
nutrition they're all interlined so bad
night's sleep means that the next next
day you're going to have a bigger sugar
Spike to the same Bagel or uh breakfast
that you had sorry sorry if I have a bad
night's sleep the same food will give me
a bigger sugar Spike yes
so it upsets all of your metabolism
right so as you were saying I feel
better after a good night sleep your
body's metabolism is also different so a
disrupted night's sleep means that uh
your body will overreact to sugar sugar
you're more like to have a sugar dip
after it and feel tired and you're more
like to feel hungry and crave more
carbohydrates after a bad night and I
think most people listening will think
of that so yeah if I really rotten night
sleep you s of get up and you your body
craves something to to help you through
this you know
and everything is is out of a sink and
people who are sleeping
poorly will have uh less healthy gut
microbes than those that don't we we
don't yet know which way around that
relationship goes whether sleep is
driving the microbiome or the microbiome
is is affecting sleep but we know
they're interrelated so the other thing
we've shown is that generally as you
found our body likes to a consistent
pattern of activity and rest so going to
sleep at the same time waking up at the
same time is really good for your body
you feel better and nourished now if
people are say changing by a couple of
hours hour and a half two hours at the
weekends they're sleeping later and
waking up later this affects also their
sugar responses and their gut microbes
so we know that this consistency of
approach is really important for
everything in your body now it doesn't
mean I don't want to tell people they
should never go out or party because you
know social networking is fun but just
think of that in mind particularly if
it's in your control and it's just you
know watching another Netflix movie you
know because it's the weekend may not be
the smartest thing to do if you want to
feel really good long term and it's this
consistency is coming out again um
linking this this idea of nutrition how
we respond to food but also involving
our gut microbes so yeah sleep is
incredibly important it's all part of
the
solistica circadian rhythm more
than many other things that we do I used
to think that light was the thing that
was had the greatest influence over my
circadian rhythm my like internal body's
clock what time my body thinks it is but
food has a big impact on that Cadian
Rhythm so absolutely yeah all the
studies are pointing to that so I used
to think like you that yeah you know
when I was going to the US or whatever
the most important thing was to get out
there and get in the sunlight and
whatever and not worry about my meals
and just eat because it when I'm
jetlagged I was always hungry anyway but
now you know really focusing on fasting
and trying to eat at the time of where
the time zone you're trying to fit into
is much more important than than
sunlight so yeah meal timings are
increasingly important in science and I
think this is one of the really new
exciting areas and it all fits in with
this idea of you know getting your your
rest periods really well worked out your
activity periods not messing them up not
eating when you're supposed to be
resting and uh not doing things out of
syn and so the people that do deal with
uh time changes and jet lag generally
they're often fasting on planes now not
eating all the food that's offered and
and thinking about what how they want to
Kickstart their new clock when they when
they get to their destination so this
idea that I had of getting my assistant
to schedule what time I work out every
day and what time I eat every day is a
good idea yeah yes as long as it doesn't
become obsessional I would say cuz some
people there's no risk of that with
me so you know people listening I think
these are often good ideas but again if
you go over the 8020 rule because you
can get obsessed about anything whether
it's exercise it's training it's
sleeping and then you get anxious about
it if you don't do it every day so
realize it's important but realize some
things are more important than your
schedule okay and things like friends
and having fun and and you know you know
absolutely crucial and this is all part
of our you know philosophy we've been
trying to build with Zoe is about food
is about enjoyment and we we mustn't
break it down to mathematical formulas
all the time got to realize that life is
important to do everything uh and you
know we can all have a day off my last
question I think is maybe one
that nobody's asked you before I'm sure
a lot of people have probably asked you
it
um I'm a dog owner
got a little French Bulldog who's 8
years old now called
Pablo when I was pouring his food out
today it dawned on me that his food is
heavily heavily heavily processed do you
have any advice on what we should be
feeding our pets our dogs our
[Music]
cats before we started Zoe I did think
of doing a gut dog dog microbiome U map
my pet uh project and I did look into
this but I'm not up to date on it but
there's lots of evidence that the the
food the pellets uh I used to give our
dogs which I thought were great are the
equivalent of ultr processed foods just
like you said and that dogs who are
given Whole Foods live longer and have
less diabetes put on weight less and are
much healthier so I believe that the
same thing that applies to humans
applies to dogs the canned stuff that
smelled horrible is is they still use
that but we were told that the pellets
were healthier and because they
contained all these extra vitamins and
it was this concentrated source that was
perfect for them and if you look at it
it's exactly the same as ultr processed
food and that's probably why our pets
are getting as obese as we are they're
getting diabetes they're getting chronic
diseases they're getting arthritis and I
think there is some evidence I'm not
sure how good it is that if you convert
them to whole food diets whole Meats
just eating
the same that uh we would might be
eating or eating our our scraps they
will do better so maybe you should try
that I I I do I was thinking this when I
saw the numbers I heard that Zoe now has
more than 100,000 members and I thought
you know getting to look at the data of
100,000 people I'm not saying that you
look at the data but just having access
to the patterns and the insights that
you get from such a huge amount of
people many of which tens of thousands
of which are inputting food Diaries
every day you must have had so many like
Eureka moments or incredible insights
from that bird's eye view that like
there must be some things that are just
you you've grown in conviction and
passion about because of that
perspective well we're seeing things
we've never seen before we've discovered
4,000 new species of
microb just you know in the last few
months uh each of these could be totally
novel or useful for Therapeutics um or
Diagnostics uh we found things like this
this parasite the blasto cytis um we're
finding links with new foods that we
could start to give people advice on
about which which foods to eat to
improve which microbe and you know as we
go forward in the future we'll be able
to perhaps predict microb uh
combinations that look like they might
prevent cancer and uh heart disease or
interact with your medications to make
anti-depressants more effective or
hormone replacement tra more effective
so
I think it's all happened so fast and it
uh and it's just incredible that the
response that we've had Zoe and the
people are all contributing their data
to this community that I you know very
soon we're going to be a million people
and it's such an exciting time for
scientists like myself knowing that uh
you know we're going to unravel all
these secrets and uh who knows where
it's going to
lead last time I asked you a question
because because when we share so much
advice on food I think it's it's nice to
close on an overarching
principle nice overarching Philosophy
for everybody to take away from this
conversation and everything we've
discussed what in your words with that
overarching principle or philosophy be
towards our health and our nutrition and
our diets you can't go wrong if you do
things that are going to be good for
your gut
microbes and so thinking on half of your
gut microbes or your pets as you call
them think what would they want to eat
how would they want you to behave and if
you do that you're going to be eating
all the right things and avoiding all
the bad things and all the rest
generally follows I think that's the
simplest device I can and you know if
and realizing that when you eat food you
know you're not alone you've got these
trillions of microbes there waiting for
your every move and your
choice
the closing tradition on this podcast is
that the last guest leaves a question
for the next guest not knowing who
they're going to leave it for and I love
this because it changes Direction a
little bit the question that's been left
for you is what is a modern positive
vision of
masculinity did you save that one
especially for
me
um have you got Sons I've got a son
yes um so I got to think like him have I
um what's a positive vision for his
masculinity and a modern
one it's probably someone who's prepared
to go 50/50 on all the chores in the
house at the moment I think that's the
uh uh I think masculinity is going
through a tough time at the moment and
um
I think uh realize there is a revolution
going on so I think it's it's definitely
about being flexible MH and losing a lot
of those those
stereotypes and uh going with a flow
that's what I would advise him too late
for me but um it's a confusing thing
that's what the guest was talking about
how young men are very confused in their
masculinity what it means what it is to
be a man what it's not to be a man these
days and really trying to give he was
that guess was really trying to give men
an answer for that question of like
young you know masculinity because the
data shows young men are suffering um
tremendously if you look at the suicide
rates or if you look at the you know um
employment rates or the education rates
or uh dating all those in those areas so
there's a bit of a as you say a
Revolution going on in masculinity and
what it means to be a man yeah don't be
ashamed to be male but be flexible and
try to adapt to the the changing world I
think that's that's it Tim thank you so
much thank you for your wisdom you've
definitely changed my life and I know
from all the feedback I got in our last
conversation you've changed the lives of
many many people through your work but
also more broadly through what Zoe's
doing I can only speak for myself
obviously I'm I have a relationship with
zo I'm an investor in the company and I
they sponsor the podcast but in my life
the key the significant changes that
I've seen because of the insight and the
the fact that Zoe has turned the lights
onto my nutrition have been I for pretty
much my whole life I had gut problems
and I didn't really know why and I just
accepted it I had was always bloated had
pains in my um my gut and I just thought
it was normal you know I thought as a
lot of people probably think I thought I
was broken in some way and this was just
the way that my body was born and then
as I've done this podcast I've realized
to not accept this idea that I was born
broken in any area of my life and to to
look a little bit more about how there
might be a misalignment between what my
body wants and what the modern world is
giving it and through Zoe I was able to
completely remove that um decade long
pain in my gut by focusing on foods that
had a good relationship with me so I
thank Zoe for that and I thank you for
that and the work that you do in
spreading the message cuz a lot of the
things you say you
know they ruffle feathers and they and I
think I think when things are positively
disruptive it's an inevitability that
they ruffle feathers because there is an
incumbent that has experienced cognitive
dissonance there's an incumbent that
feels threatened or challenged in such a
way but I think that's how Innovation
and positive change occurs so thank you
pleasure hope it
works let's talk about Zoe who you may
know because they're a sponsor of this
podcast and I'm an investor in the
company you guys know health is my
number one priority Zoe's growth story
has been absolutely incredible so far
they're doing science at a scale that
I've never seen before because of their
members and recent breakthroughs in
research they can now continue to offer
the most scientifically Advanced gut
health test on the market previously the
test allowed them to analyze 30 bacteria
types in your gut but now thanks to new
science they've identified 100 bacteria
types this is a huge step forward and
there's nothing else that's available
even close to it on the market at all so
to find out more and to get started on
your Zoe Journey visit zoe.com
stepen you can use my exclusive code
ce10 for 10% off don't tell anybody
about that okay just for you
guys
[Music]
oh